okay this is the story the first time
that I told somebody I'd loved him
[Music]
I feel you know many will say that it
was like a beautiful day like today in
front of a fountain with the music
playing in the back but it was um you
know we were just in her in her home we
were just watching TV on her bed and
while watching the show I couldn't I
couldn't focus on what was going on in
the movie because I was taken by the
emotions I was started to realize and
feel a lot of nowhere and you know I
just looked at her and I told her you
know that I love you and it was because
I really did feel it you know I felt
like I needed her know because you never
know if tomorrow was granted or not her
reciprocating it was like the pillow
that I needed you know because you know
saying I love you so risky it's like if
I'm dropping my head back and if you
don't hear her back or say it back
you're just gonna slam your head very
hard to something but she was that
pillow that kind of reassured me like
all right you know everything's gonna
we had been dating for a month which
really isn't that long but I just felt
it I knew it I knew it was different and
I really wanted him to say it first
because I was too scared so I remember
one night when I was saying goodbye
because we were doing kind of a
long-distance thing I was hugging him
and I was saying I really really really
liked you he was like yeah I really
really like you too
but I was really digging into it I like
no you don't get it really like yeah and
I was listing off all these things that
I loved about him like I love to smile I
love his hair and laughs laughs I love
his kindness and love his personality
and he caught on and he just said I love
you I love you too
I kind of pushed him into a little bit
but he wanted to say it too so it worked
out it's kind of embarrassing and I
probably should like never go online in
it but this but I told someone I loved
them and then I parted could they heard
it I was like I hope they didn't hear
that and they did they definitely heard
it I was like getting all the car I was
like love you and it's like one of those
things are like slips when you like
doesn't want to say it yet and then you
did and as I was getting off the car
that and they're like I did I've changed
since then I like learned to fart
earlier on with people so that way like
if it accidently just how I can just
really I totally plan that okay okay I
think the first time I told someone I
that would have been my best friend at
the time it was mutual we loved each
other and I think I even gave her a
little blue ring I had that was before I
was interested in boys
that first love is so innocent you're
not looking for anything you are a blank
slate and you just know what you love
and it's straight from our later on you
look for things you look for qualities
or and there's a blueprint later on but
in the first love is just straight from
the heart it doesn't matter what someone
looks like doesn't matter if they're
your best friend it doesn't matter what
sex they are it doesn't matter how much
money they have it's just from the heart
the first time I told somebody I loved
them I was probably in kindergarten his
leg Oh God or I think it was like a GI
Joe got stuck in a tree and I got it
because I was always haulin and he gave
me kiss on the cheek and I told him my
love I never really knew love was I
thought I did it was something I wanted
but I never knew what it was honestly
until I met this one right here
okay you know I've had like I guess they
call it puppy love I don't know I
thought it was love but when I met him
like that's when I experienced love
you'd lose yourself in puppy love
cuz you saw about the other person I
know you lose who you are you feel like
you tolerating their behavior he asked
me how do i how do I tolerate him and
normally was wasting a question you know
like because this this this but when he
accident I was like I don't tolerate you
I love you like can you explain the
studying how you said it exactly we were
in the bed we were in the bed and I was
just describing everything I loved about
him but I didn't say I love you and then
he asked me he said you love everything
else about me but me and I was like I do
though so that's my first time I love
different it's different you know it
when you get it our promise you will
know it like that's my husband next time
y'all see us you'll see us married tell
you
so when I was 16 I had a boyfriend and
he would always say I love you too I
love YouTube just so like he wouldn't
have to say I love you like when I first
started dating she was awkward he's like
a really funny ginger and so one day
he's like I love you and I was like tube
and he's like no tube we said I love you
for the first times were in seven 16
years old okay I really have I did
member it oh yeah I had an ex-girlfriend
I killed for a lot but I don't think I
ever actually told her it's not in the
record I love you so how would you
express to her I only just put all time
together all three have researched a lot
like hardships a lot of darkness we both
carried so you were feeling it I like
looking back yeah it definitely was and
I guess nobody thought about so now
actually
comics opportunity I guess have you been
in love since
it was actually over text some dumb and
I couldn't like properly express myself
fun and so I was feeling kind of sad and
he's just really nice
he's like my children to Leela just
level a lot he said I think I love you
too I love him more than all the stars
in the galaxy
you
I never told anyone that I love you that
I love him okay okay and what would you
tell me earlier
ah and I hope and I hope that never do
it you hope that you never say anyone
love you I love you Oh God because I
don't see the point
everyone say I love you I want to say
anything else anything differently now
something that really means something I
don't know how to say I think this
meaning of I love you is empty we say if
I loved that thing
oh I love no se que that some feel but
when you I don't know why the person who
actually you know say I don't know but I
love you it's empty its mainstream so
it's not that you don't want to find
this connection you just don't want to
express it in those ways I don't know I
mean this connection really exists
do you believe in more oh yeah of course
so your sister went before you and she
doesn't but yes I believe in love
yes I I hope to find someone really
special to me and I don't know maybe
spend all my life with him it was
Halloween
I was Tiger Lily and he was Captain Hook
we had a Halloween party at my house
where
I think maybe I was like holding a space
in my hands and I said don't make me say
it
don't make me say that I love you it was
really nice so it's the last time I felt
like the words I love you I really
needed to say was when I left my home in
San Jose to come here to San Diego you
know I really felt like I needed to say
to my parents and I really didn't tell
him my plan or intention of moving down
in San Diego and me my parents we don't
really have a great relationship in
terms of like being communicative and
expressing to our feelings towards each
other you know I've been in San Diego
for almost four years and I've only seen
my parents like once or twice every year
and further I like I'm away from them I
really like feel like man I really wish
I said I love you to them when I left
you know and you know I until this day
too like it's really it's a struggle for
me to say I love you to my parents if I
could say it right now I would I would
say it like a million times you know so
yeah would you be down to call them
right now
sure and tell them you love them oh yeah
I'm gonna call it I'm coming home right
now I want to tell that I love her okay
quitting on me
um and no I mean I gonna I love you mom
I'm sorry I know I know yeah yeah yeah
well didn't but I can also you know
Billa
a day in a corner and Congo me what I
mean you come why so that's why I can
bill you know me but I take a gun turn
burner and so yeah yeah I know I'm sorry
[Music]
Wow okay
oh wow really all right welcome Eli oh
yeah oh yeah it was like one a little
bit lecture a little bit of tough love a
little bit of like what are you doing
your life a little bit of you know all
that but at the end of it like you know
like she was just like making sure that
was okay I sometimes get into a deep
space where I feel like nobody's
watching me and you know it's because
you know being in this big city you
really like you really took a toll on me
just like thinking that like I was alone
but you know I always remembered out I
made a lot of friends here and I have a
business partner and I have you know my
family and I have the grace of God just
like watching over me you know so I'm
not I'm not completely alone it's just
at times that are tough like you know I
love you is really powerful when so
that's what I said it so for me the most
memorable moment I have where I said I
love you was to my late mom who passed
away I'd say around three years ago it
was on her deathbed where I did say I
love you I do remember around like two
months prior is when she started to lose
her voice it was getting very straining
for her to do anything at all she was
mostly bedridden for that last two
months that we had her here it was one
dark night me my dad and her were all
together in the room and we were just
you know as we normally did during that
time we were just together in silence
not really saying anything there wasn't
really much to that need to be said at
one point my dad did kind of close in on
me he came in or he like stood next to
my ear and you whisper to me that it's
okay to cry and you know when you hear
those words right in those types of
situations you tend to let go so
obviously I ended up crying solving you
know all that ugly stuff that no one
really wants to go through and I hope no
one does ever but
um and I do remember you know with my
head down sobbing she put her hands up
to my hair and started playing with my
hair like I you know how she did when I
was a little kid and so I look up you
know and she's staring at me and I tell
her I love you mom and she said it back
to which obviously I I wouldn't say that
like I lost it right for lack of a
better word but it really did hit really
to you I don't think I've ever like
received or have experienced any type of
that love like when she said I love you
and it not only was like loud and clear
it had this weight to it you know when
she said I love you I really did feel
that I'll throw in my body and I'll
throw out my head too and so I'm really
glad that you know I was able to
experience one last time at least before
she passed away
you
everyone happy early Valentine's Day as
always thank you for watching another
episode if you enjoy watching my videos
and you want to watch more please make
sure to subscribe button and the ball
next to it so you'll get notified every
Thursday morning when I upload thank you
guys again for everything and I'll see
you next week